[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار استهلوها بابره
العناوين
رئيس الوزراء ووزير الداخليه والاستخبارات
بمحاوله اغتياله
المتكرره الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
تؤكد لم نجد دليلا على اعداد كياب لقنبله
قذره
زياره مستشار الالماني الى بكين تغضب
واشنطن والتشوز يتعهدوا بعدم تجاهل
القضايا الجدليه
والامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق من السعوديه
اول شركه لتصنيع السيارات الكهربائيه في
الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
محاوله اغتيال الفاشله نجع منها رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان
بينما كان ينادي باجراء انتخابات مبكرا
عمليه فاشله لم يتردد عمران خان اتهام
سلفه رئيس الوزراء الحي الشعبي الشريف
وزير الداخليه ومسؤول استخباراتيه بالوقوف
وراء تدبيرها لا بل ان عمران خان كان على
علم مسبق بحدوث هكذا محاولات وفقا لرئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق اتهامات قد
ينجم عنها غضب شعبيه لانصار حزب انصاف وقد
تعود بهم الى شارع مره اخرى اذا لم يتم
طرد المتهمين من مناصبهم وفقا لتهديدات
عمر خالد
ينضم الينا من اسلام اباد عبد الرحمن
المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن هل من
انباء عن صحه عمران خان وما هي اخر
التطورات من هناك
في حالته مستقره وتم ازاله بعض
عمليه اطلاق النار
التي اجريت له مساء هذا اليوم اما ميدانيا
خرجت ااا عده مظاهرات في عده مدن
باكستانيه همم تمديدا بمحاوله الاغتيال
الفاشله ضد رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
لاسيما في اقليم البنجاب وفي اقليم خيبر
بقدوم واحد في يسيطر حزب الانصار زعامه
عمران خان على الحكومه في هذين الاقليميش
مظاهره كبيره في مدينه كراتشي وكان هناك
بعض
حيث قام
باغلاق بعض الطرق وهوما ادى الى اختناقات
مروريه ايضا هناك
مؤرث توتر في مدينه فيصل اباد وهي المدينه
التي ينحدر منها رئيس اصلا لوزير الداخليه
الباكستاني رنا سنه الله كانت هناك همم
كان
هناك قضيه الحجاره ما بين انصار رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان
وحراس منزل لوزير الداخليه وكان هناك عن
انه جرى اطلاق نار لكن لم يتم همم لم يؤدي
ذلك الى وقوع ضحايا همم الان الاوضاع بدات
تعود نوعا ما همم الى همم الى طبيعتها
تدرجين في عدد من المناطق باستثناء بعض
المناطق التي لا يزال فيها بعض المسار
رئيس وزراء
السابقون في الشارع همم
ان يكون يوم غدا يوم عاشوما همم امين عام
حزب الانصاف زعامه عمران خان بان همم
المسيره الطويله التي كان يقودها رئيس
وزراء عمران خان سوف
حراكها يوم غدا الجمعه همم المتوقع ان
تؤدي هذه عمليه عمليه الفاشله الى ضخ مزيد
من الدماء من الدماء وربما
الحياه الى هذه المسيره التي راها كثير من
المراقبين بانها لم لم ترقى الى ما كان
يتوقع حزب الانصاف وقاده حزب الانصاف خلال
الايام السبعه الماضيه من هذه المسيره
شكرا لك عبد الرحمن المزاني مراسل العربيه
حدثنا من اسلام اباد
ظهر رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان امام الكاميرات بعد نجاته من عمليه
اطلاق النار التي تعرض لها وتشهد باكستان
عمليات اغتيال منذ سنوات عديده استهدفت
فاعلين سياسيين باكستانيين نستعرض
مشاهدينا شريط احداث استهداف موقف عمران
خان في سياق التقرير التاليه
[موسيقى]
خلال السنوات الاخيره بعد اشهر من الاطاحه
بحكومه من قبل البرلمان عاد الي يقود
مسيره تطالب بانتخابات مبكرا في الطريق
الى العاصمه الاسلام بعد لم يكن احد يتوقع
ان يكون الرصاص لغه الغاليه خلال المناسبه
بدل تصريحات المعتده من خان
انها محاوله يقول حزب الانصاف رصاصه واحده
اصابه رئيس الوزراء السابق في قدمه لكنه
نجا من موت محقق
نقل الرجل الى المستشفى قبل ان يظهر امام
عدسات الكاميرات ملوحا لانصاره بنجاته تم
قتل احد المهاجرين اخر حسب احد كبار مساعد
في مثل هذه الاحداث اظهرت الصور شخصا وهو
يحاول انقاذ المستهدف في العمليه
وزير الاعلام السابق من جهته اكد ان شخصا
كان يحمل مسدس اوتوماتيكيا اطلق رشقه
واصيب كل من كان يقف في الصف الامامي
اقر بانه اراد قتل خان قائلا انه تصرف
بشكل مستقل لكن روايه المقربين من خان
تتحدث عن محاوله اغتيال سياسي
باكستان ومنذ عقود تشهد عمليات اغتيال
استهدفت سياسيين كانت ابرزهم رئيسه
الوزراء سابقا بنظر بوتو بلد لم يكمل فيه
اي رئيس للوزراء ولايته منذ 75 سنه
العربيه
تسرب بطنك ترابرا
[موسيقى]
حركه الانصاف الباكستانيه التي ينتمي
اليها عمران خان تعد من اكبر الاحزاب في
باكستان باكثر من 10 ملايين منتمي تاسست
عام 1996 وحصدت اكبر عدد اصوات في تاريخ
باكستان عام 2018
[موسيقى]
كده
المدير العام
يرصده اي انشطه او مواد نوويه لم يعلن
عنها بعد اكتمال التفتيش الميدانيه في
ثلاثه مواقع في اوكرانيا وقال جروسي في
البيان ان عمليات التفتيش الميداني تمت في
المواقع الثلاثه بناءا على طلب الحكومه
الاوكرانيه مشيرا لان الوكاله مستعده
للقيام بمزيد من عمليات التفتيش هناك
لتاكد من عدم وجود انشطه ومواد نوويه من
هذا القبيل
اما في اخر التطورات الميدانيه اكدت وكاله
سبوتنيك الروسيه سماع دويجارات قويه في
مدينه مليتوبول بمقاطعه زابوريج الجنوبيه
اوكرانيا ما استدعى تفعيل انظمه الدفاع
الجوي لتجنب خسائر في غضون ذلك افادت
مصادر اعلاميه اوكرانيه بوقوع انفجارات في
كل من خرسون وميكولايف ونيكوبول جانبي
البلاد كما قال الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه 80 هجوما براجمات الصواريخ تضررت
على اثرها اكثر من 20 مدينه وبلده هذا
واشار الجيش الاوكراني الى هجمات الروسيه
في كيرفيري بواسطه اوكرانيا وسومي وحركات
في شمال الشرقيه وحدث قتال شرس في منطقتين
لوجان البلاد
قوه امريكيه في اوكرانيا قد تتسبب بصدام
المباشر بين موسكو والغرب لكن هدف هذه
الفرقه هو تعقب وحصر استخدام الاسلحه
الاكثر تقدما التي يتم توريدها الى
اوكرانيا ضمن حزمه المساعدات العسكريه حيث
كشفت مجله
بشؤون الدفاعيه ان الولايات المتحده تعتزم
نشر عناصر من الجيش الامريكي في اوكرانيا
لتفقد استخدام الاسلحه الغربيه كما اشارت
الى ان هذه الخطوه يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اصطدام واسع النطاق بين روسيا من جهه
وتعطي مسارا جديدا لنزاع الحاصل على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وسيؤدي طبعا الى مشاكل
في حاله اصابه اي جندي امريكيه هناك
[موسيقى]
انا هيك راح
اقول لك ارقام الجنود الاوكرانيون ملاجئ
مؤقتا شبه امنه تحت الارض مع بدء فصل
الشتاء للاحتماء من البرد القارس وتمكن من
الطهي والنوم حيث نشرت وزاره الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه على حسابها في التويتر صور
تظهر من خلال استعدادات الجنود
الاوكرانيين للحرب خلال فصل الشتاء المقبل
هذا مؤكد ان فصل الشتاء لن يكون سهلا على
الجيش
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من عبر سكوب مكياج
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
موضوع تصدير الحبوب بما انه الموضوع الاهم
عالميا اليوم روسيا بالرغم من عودتها الى
اتفاقيه التصدير الى انها تلوح بورقه
جديده الان وهو موضوع موضوع عدم التجديد
لهذا الاتفاق ماذا يعني ذلك وكيف ستتصرفك
شكرا على ضيافتي مساء الخير تحيه من كيف
الحمد لله لدينا كهرباء اليوم وانا معكم
صفقه حبوب او صفقه زراعيه تستمر الحمد لله
من ناحيه اوكرانيا مرتاحه جدا
اقتصاديه
وسياسيا
وانسانيه
دوله واحده تركيا كمان مرتاحه وتسعدنا
كثير في تصدير منتجات زرعيه اوكرانيه الى
دول افريقيا الى دور اوروبيه الى دول اسيا
ولابد من نتذكر
الحديث الصفقه
اما روسيا انا لا اعتقد بان لها اي دور
الان بهذه السر خلينا خصيصا بعد الدرب
يعني مش معروف حتى الان من ضربه الشراع
شراء
وبعد ادرار سفينتين نفتكر هناك
روسيا الان ضعيفه جدا في بحر الاسود في ما
يخص
الاسطول البحري لان تركيا يمكن اقوى من
روسيا بعده مره
استاذ نيفين اعاده فتح ملف مولدوفا
وتحديدا ترانسليت التي تعتبر من المناطق
الانفصاليه التابعه نوعا ماء لموسكو اليوم
مولدوفا يعني تقول بانها ممكن ان تعلن
التعبئه الجزئيه في حال حصل اي تغيير على
الحدود الاوكرانيه المولدوفيا هل تلمسون
اي يعني بادره التحرك روسيه من هذه الجبهه
نحن جدا
ليش لان مولدوفا قريبه لنا
دوله صديقه الحمد لله ولكن هناك زي يعني
شريت كده همم ترانس ميستريا شريط اللي
بيحكم هناك انصار روسيا كمان وهناك يعني
لا تتذكر تماما ولكن
10,000 الجنود
والدبابات الروس
يحافظون هذه ثانيه
لا تزال موجوده في الشمال
دوله روس لنا
كثير من همم صواريخ
الروسيه
وكذلك كثير من مسيرات ايرانيه
136 كمان تم اطلاقها من بيلاروسيا شوف كيف
لا تزال هناك كمان همم
وعد الى حد ما خطير في جنوب اوكرانيا في
جنوب الان الجيش الاوكراني يستمر في
الهجوم
الرعب النووي او حرب اللعب على اعصاب
العالم من خلال التهديد النووي التي اليوم
تنتجها كل من اكياف ومن روسيا فيكيا سمعنا
تقرير الوكاله الدوليه التي تقول بان لا
قنبله قذره وايضا هناك تقارير غربيه تتهم
موسكو بدراسه المجلس العسكري لاحتماليات
استخدام النووي ماذا يعني ذلك
انا مش
الوكاله الدوليه ذريه ولكن انا واكد لان
عنده برانيه لا توجد اي قنبله [__] او
قنبله قذره زي ما يسموها ولا قنبله نوويه
تاريخيه
20 30 سنه كانت تستخدم في الطاقه
الكهربائيه اكثر من 50% طاقه من محطه
كهربائيه
15 مولد قهر النووي
اسف الشديد حتى الان ولا تزال منذ شهرين
وحتى اكثر حتى واحده اكبر محطه في اوروبا
في مدينه
وهي مختلفه من قبل الروس الشيخ
جدا وبالتالي وانتم ما زلتم تلمسون خطر
نووي روسي حتى الساعه بالرغم من نافي
موسكو شكرا
لدينا خبره سيئه جدا على 1986 محطه
شرنوبيل نحن نعرف شو يعني القنبله اييه
[__]
اعوذ بالله اعوذ بالله
شكرا لك استاذ ياسين
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني حدثنا منك
البوصله الروسيه تتوجه نحو موندوفاجرت كل
من اوكرانيا ورومانيا لتنذر بتكرار
سيناريو التوتر وربما الحرب الدائره بين
موسكو وكياس سقوط شظايا صواريخ روسيه على
بلده نسلافجه المولدوفيا الحدوديه كانت
كفيله باشعال فتيل التوتر بين الطرفين
مولدوفا دقت ناقوس الخطر وقامت بطرد
دبلوماسيه بالسفاره الروسيه من اراضيها
وموسكو توعدت بالرد اللائق والمناسبه
درستي ستريم نحن نعيش في اوقات ماساويه
وحاسمه ونحتاج الى بعضنا البعض اليوم نعيش
حقيقه حرب مرعبه على حدودنا حرب تقتل
الابرياء في اوكرانيا وتعرض حريه الجميع
للخطر في منطقتنا
التطورات الاخيره في المشهد السياسي
للبلاد وما صاحبها من احتجاجات ضد سياسه
الحكومه المواليه للغرب زادت من وتيره
الصراع الاقليميه على الانتماء الدوله
الصغيره المرشحه لعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
وفق مراقبين فلقد كشفت تقارير استخباراتيا
نشرتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان روسيا ارسلت
فريق من الاستراتيجيين السياسيين الروس
لتقديم المشهوره لحزب المعارضه في مولدوفا
بقيادته الى
قامت بشراء اصول وممتلكات للمعارض الى
انشور بهدف حمايتها من النظام على حد
قولها وهو نفس النهج الذي تم اعتماده مع
المعارضين للنظام الاوكرانيه قبل بدء
عملياتها العسكريه في شهر فبراير الماضي
كما افادت تقارير الغربيه بتورط روسيا عن
طريق ديبلوماسيحيها في تجنيد مواطنين
مندفيين للقتال الى جانب الانفصاليين
الاوكرانيين
نحن حزب مستقل تماما ولا يدافع الا عن
موقف في مواطن مولدوفا الحكومه مسؤوله عن
انهيار الوضع الاقتصادي
اقبل موندوفا السياسي والاقتصادي بات
مرهون بالصراع الدائر بين روسيا والغرب
وخصوصا وان موسكو بات تستغل تراجع الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه وازمه نقص امدادات الطاقه
كوراقه ضغط على النظام في البلاد فمولدوفا
وقبل العقوبات الغربيه المفروضه كانت
تعتمد على الغاز الروسي بنسبه 100% والذي
تراجع لنحو 30 بالمئه بسبب مواقفها نهيك
عن انها تعيش الان اسوء ازمه كهرباء بعد
ضرب محطات الطاقه في اوكرانيا والتي دفعها
للجوء الى رومانيا
[موسيقى]
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
[تصفيق]
استراتيجيته القمعيه الجديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خطوه فرديه تجاه الصين
قد تتسبب بابعادها عن الغرب 10 خطوات
عواقب محتمله قد تنجم عن زياره المستشار
الفوز الى بيكين هذه الزياره تبدا يوم غد
وتاتي في توقيت الحساس لعده امور اولا
انها تتزامن مع اجتماعات مجموعه السبع في
المانيا اضافه الى التوتر الامريكي الصيني
حاليا وهذا ما قد يزود الامر سوءا بين
برلين وواشنطن التي ستلتزم بمراقبه ما
سيتم تناوله في هذا الزياره كونها لم
تستطع ثاني شوز عن الغائها ليس خارجيا فقط
بل حتى داخليا تعرض شو ضد الانتقادات من
سياسيين وصحف محليه حيث اثارت هذه الزياره
تساؤلات عما اذا كان الاعتماد الكبير
للصناعه الالمانيه على الصين يعرض برلين
لمخاطر مستقبليه المستشار الالمانيه لما
زيارته اقتصاديه بحث ويسعى من خلالها الى
التوازن داعيا الى ضروره تغيير اسلوب
التعاون مع التكين وهو ما اثار حفيظه
حلفاء برلين من الغرب لكن ولتخفيف الضغط
على نفسه بعد موجه الانتقادات الخارجيه
والداخليه اشار شوز الى ان زيارته الى
الصين ولقائه المتوقع مع الرئيس جين بينج
لن يتم خلالها تجاهل القضايا المثيره
للجدل
[موسيقى]
من جهتها قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان
التعاون بين بكين وبيرين مهم وليس لواشنطن
اي حق في التدخل بينهما جاء ذلك ردا على
التصريحات التي اطلقتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والتي ابدت قلقها من التعاون
الصينيه الالماني وفتح المانيا المجال
امام الصين في الاستثمار في الموانئ
الالمانيه
بين الصين والمانيا امر يخص البلدين ولا
ينبغي للولايات المتحده ان تهاجمه بدون
سبب وليس لها الحق في التدخل المسؤولون
الامريكيون يشعرون بالرضا حينما يتدخلون
في شؤون البلدان الاخرى بما في ذلك ما
يسمى بالدول الشركه ما يكشف عقليه الهيمنه
لديهم وسلبيات الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
معنى من واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير
في الشؤون السياسيه الدكتور عقيل يعني منذ
فتره طويله
السياسه الالمانيه الخارجيه دائما هي بضل
سياسات الولايات المتحده بدات تتميز نوعا
ماء مع طرح موسكو نفسها كلاعب دوله اليوم
محاوله التوازن بين علاقه اقتصاديه مع
الصين وبين الحفاظ على العلاقه السياسيه
مع واشنطن هل ممكن ان تنجح
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه يعني اعتقد ان
الجهد الالماني بالتواصل مع الصين
اقتصاديا في هذه المرحله اثارت قلقا
امريكيا لكنها ايضا اثارت قلقا اوروبيا
وقلقا حتى في داخل المانيا
وجهه النظر الامريكيه هي التاليه انه
علينا ان نتعلم من دروس
الحرب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا المانيا اعتمدت
برغم التحضيرات الامريكيه على الغاز
الروسي في عهد مركز ورفضت
انجل مركب في حينها البحث عن بدائل
حدثت هذه الحرب
وواجهت المانيا مشكله
نفطيه مشكله طاقه كبيره هي تحت حقيقه
الضغط الروسي هذا هو الفهم الامريكي صح ام
خطا شيء اخر الان تحاجز الولايات المتحده
ومعها شركاء اوروبي بالمناسبه انه ال ال
المستشار شغل يكرر نفس الخطا عبر فتحه
مسارات خاصه مع الصين تؤدي الى اعتماد
المانيا على الصين هو ربما
ستندم المانيا على هدف المستقبل
اليوم جزء يعني من هذا التوجه الا تتحمله
الولايات المتحده بسبب عدم استدراكها ل-
اا يعني عدم مساعدتها لاوروبا على تحمل
تبعات الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
يعني الامريكيون يشعرون انهم بذلوا اعطوا
الاموال اعطل الادوات في هذه الحرب هم
يحاولون ان يساعدون اوروبا هذا هو الاحساس
الامريكي همم بهذا بخصوص ايضا بخصوص
الصفقه يعني التواصل الصيني الالماني
اقتصاديا انا لا اعتقد انه شخص او الحكومه
الالمانيه وقفت بالضمن الولايات المتحده
الحقيقه يعني صفقه الميناء ميناء هامبو
كان هناك ضغط امريكي همم على الحكومه
الالمانيه ان يتم تخفيض مقدار الصفحه ان
تتحكم يعني بحدود 25% بدل من 35% الذي
يعطيها يعني حق الفيتو على قرارات معينه
والشمس اخذ بنظر الاعتبار التحفظ
الامريكيه يعني انا لست من الذين يعني همم
الصراع بين اوروبا وامريكا
تاخذ مسارها الخاص الا يعني هذا بدا
التفسخ الحقيقي بالموقف الاوروبي ويعني
نجاح الرهان الروسي على على هذا الموضوع
بالذات
يعني بالامكان النظري اليها بهذه الطريقه
اعتقد انت واصلت مثل هذه الاعمال والافعال
مستقبلا ومن دول اوروبيه مختلفه لحد الان
نحن نتحدث عن فعل واحد في سياق او ساعه له
معارضه اوروبيه نعرف انه ما اكرهن اعترض
على هذه الزياره عرضها على المستشار
الالمانيه ان يذهبها سوريه في وقت مختلف
بعيدا عن همم
يعني المؤتمر الذي عقده الحزب الشيعي
الصيني همم من اجل عدم اعطاء او بعث رساله
للصين وحتى للولايات المتحده والشغل فقط
مبكر جدا القول ان المانيا تحاول ان
تختصارا منفصلا عن شركائها الاوروبيين وعن
الولايات المتحده نحن نتحدث عن افعال
منفرده في سياقات ليست عامه اذا ظهرت
افعال اخرى مختلفه
الرومانيه فانا اعتقد نعم
ولكن بتوقيتات دقيقه شكرا لك يا دكتور
عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون السياسي حدثنا
من واشنطن
نبقى في الصين رجل ظل يقف خلف المسيره
التي يقودها الرئيس الصيني الرابط تسويات
الاقتصاديه
ومؤيد الاعمال التجاريه لشنكه الرجل
الايمن الجديد يعتبر من اهم الشخصيات
المواليه للرئيس الصيني والذي سيكون قادرا
على تنفيذ السياسات بكين بفاعليه وقوه دون
الخشيه من دفع حدود حكم الحزب الشيوعي
وفقا مراقبين
يمكن ان يكون له تاثير معتدل على الرئيس
الصيني في المرحله المقبله خصوصا وانه كان
من المساعدين المقربين لرئيس البلاد الذي
بدا فتره ولايته الثالثه بعد حمله لقمعا
حمله قمعا لايعارضه محتمله له ولعل سبب
اعتماد الرئيس الصيني على شان هو خبرتها
الاقتصاديه وايضا علاقاته الوسيطه مع
اباطره التكنولوجيا في الصين حيث عملت
كوسيط في الخلاف كان بين الرئيس الصيني
وشركه علي بابا التجاريه الضخمه عندما
اتخذت الحكومه الصينيه اجراءات صارمه ضدها
كما ان لديه مبادرات جيده واثبت في الكثير
من المرات ولاؤه للرئيس الصيني خصوصا في
حرب الرقائق الالكترونيه فهو من كانت زاعم
لفكره رفع الضرائب عن اكبر المصانع
الصينيه حتى تستطيع تصنيع رقائق محليه
فالاستراتيجيات التي يعتمد عليها لي تشانغ
تستهدف تطوير الاقتصاد وتحقيق اكبر قدر من
الثروه كما ان على علاقته مع الرئيس
الصيني والتي تعود الى اوائل العقد الاول
من القرن الحالي ستعطيه مساحه اكبر لتجربه
الافكار الجديده وتفويض المزيد من صلاحيات
اليه حتى يتمكن الرئيس من التركيز اكثر
على مساله الامن القومي والاديولوجيه
السياسيه ويشير تعيينه في المركز الثاني
الجديد لرئيس البلاد الى انه من المرشح
يصبح رئيسا للوزراء في الدورات التشريعيه
السنويه في الصين في الربيع المقبل
[موسيقى]
تغيير مستمر في السياسه القمع الاراديه
علها تنفع في ايقاف الاحتجاجات التي خرج
ضد النظام بعد مقتل الشاب الكرديه على يد
ما تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق احدث استراتيجيات
الامن الايراني وبوامر من كبار قاده
الحارسه الثوري هي زياده وتيره قمع الطلبه
المحتاجين سيامه طلاب الجامعات وفقا
لتقرير المعارضه الايرانيه والذي كشف عن
طرق هذه الاستراتيجيه التي تستند الى نشر
اكبر عدد ممكن من عناصر البسيج المسلحه
والاستخباراتيه في ساحات التي تشهد عاده
زخما في الاحتجاجات كالتي في العاصمه
طهران مثلا وايضا في الشيراز واصفهان وقم
وقردستان بلوشستان وذلك بتوزيعهم منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى اي قبل بدا التجمعات
الطلابيه والتركيز على كشف قاده
الاحتجاجات داخل تلك الجامعات اضافه لضرب
الطلاب بشده واعتقالهم باستخدام انواع
مختلفه من
تنفيذ هجمات ليليه بملابس مدنيه على
الاقسام الداخليه المخصصه لسكن الاناث
والذكور وخطف الطلاب من منظمين المظاهرات
الى جانب استخدام الاسلحه ضد بقيه الطلاب
لمنع تدخلهم تصويره طلاب من قبل عملاء
المخابرات الذين يتجولون بملابس مدنيه
وارسال طائرات مسيره فوق التجمعات لتصوير
الطلاب لكشفه هوياتهم سيامه وان مقاطع
احتجاجات التي ينشرها النشاطا تقوم بتمويه
وجوه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
في ايران ايضا حيث باتت سلسله الاعتقالات
والاعترافات القصريه تتعدى صفوف السياسيين
والناشطين وتصل الى نجوم من الوسط الفني
الايراني نشاهد التفاصيل في تقرير
صور كهذه كانت كافيه لارسال رساله واضحه
فالنظام في ايران لن يوفر طريقه للبقاء
ولو بقمع المحتجين واعتقالهم ومحاكمتهم
وحتى الحكم على بعضهم بالاعدام
والاعطاء طابع قانونيين لعمليات القمع
يحاول النظام الحصول على اعترافات من
الموقوفين وطريقته واحده الضغط والتعذيب
بعدها تبث الاعترافات على وسائل الاعلام
الرسميه هذا ما جرى مع عشرات الموقوفين
ومن بينهم مغني الراب الايراني المعروف
باغانيه الداعمه للاحتجاجات العامه
والاضطرابات العماليه خلال السنوات
الاخيره
لم يكتفي بالاغاني التي نشرها وتفاعل معها
الشارع الايراني بل ابهرت مقاطع فيديو
خروجه لمشاركته في المظاهرات الشعبيه التي
عمت البلاد
بل وخرج ايضا في مقطع فيديو مصور يطالب
فيه المسؤولين الايرانيين بالهروب في
اشاره منه على توسع الاحتجاجات في ايران
اعتقلت السلطات الايرانيه توماج وبعدها
بايام بثت له فيديو يتراجع فيه عن ما قاله
في الفيديو الذي خاطب فيه المسؤولين
الايرانيين ويقول اخطات لم اكن اقصدكم
الفيديو الذي يثبت تعرضه ماجد صالح
للترهيب والتعذيب نشراته وكاله انباء
تسنيم وفارس بهدف ارسال رساله تهديد
وتخويف للمتظاهرين المستمرين في
احتجاجاتهم
الاعترافات القسريه من المعارضين
السياسيين والنشطاء المدنيين وتصويرها
وبثها على وسائل الاعلام الحكوميه ليست
بجديده
ولم تقتصر على الموقوفين الايرانيين بل
ايضا على موقف للجنسيات اجنبيه وهو ما دفع
عده دول من بينها المانيا لدعوه مواطنها
لمغادرته ايران سلطان العربيه
ينضم الينا من اوصله عماره عضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه استاذ عمار امام ضرب
قلب شرعيه النظام الثوريه ويعني اليوم
الضغط على كل ما يفعله النظام هل ينفع
التصوير وما سيقوم به بالجامعات من محاوله
لتشتيت التظاهرات
النظام يحاول استخدام شتى الاساليب لقمع
المتظاهرين والمواجهه المحتجين وخاصه طلاب
طلاب طلاب الجامعه والتلاميذ المدارس
من مواليد التسعينات من مواليد 2000
وهؤلاء هم جيل جديد لم ينشروا على
ايديولوجيا النظام لم يتاثر
بالدعايه التي كان يبثها النظام وهم جيل
جديد نشاوا في وسط مختلف تماما الوسط الذي
همم
يوفره لهم الانترنت
والعاب الجاي وغيرها وهما منفصلين تماما
عما يجب النظام لا يفهمون لغه النظام ولا
يفهمون سياسه النظام فاعتقد هؤلاء لا تنفع
معها مثل هذه الاساليب لانهم تواقين الى
الحريه والتخلص من هذا النظام بدرجه
الاولى
من جهه والنظام من جهه اخرى هل يمكن القول
بان مزيد من القمع يعني مزيد من
الاحتجاجات ومزيد من النزول الى الشارع
بطبيعه الحال لانه النظام اختار الطريقه
الغير صحيحه لمواجهه المحتاجين بدلا من ان
يعترف بوجود اخطاء او او كل سلوكاد النظام
اخطاء ولكنه حتى لا يستطيع ان يعترف يعني
ولكن اعتقد انه اختار الطريقه الخطا
لمواجهه المحتاجين مثلا بدلا ما يبحث عن
همم اساس المشكله اساس المشاكل التي همم
موجوده يتجه الى قمح هؤلاء او تسميتهم
بالمرتزقه او ربطهم بالخارج او تسميه همم
عناصر التي تمودها الجهاد الاجنبيه انه لا
يبحث عن السبب الحقيقي للمشكله لان السبب
الحقيقي للمشكله النظام نفسه وبالتالي نحن
اليوم نتحدث عن ازمه عجز النظام الذي اتكل
على التغذيه هذا يعني الجيولوجيا على حساب
الاداء المؤسسات على حساب السماع ل- لهم
الناس ول- مطالب الناس اليوم هل نحن امام
ما دم مستمر في ايران
حتى الان ما استطعناه ان نوثقه من عدد
الضحايا هو
187 والعدد اكثر بكثير ولكننا لم نستطيع
لزياده عدد الضحايا ولي التفوق بعد
المحتاجين والمتظاهرين من مراجعه
المستشفيات او الاتصال بالجهات الحقوقيها
في الخارج لابلاق حاله الوفاه او حاله
الاصابه بالرصاص واا لا شك ان النظام همم
لا لا يستطيع ان يتخذ اسلوب اخر ولا يعمل
مراجعه على سلوك الشيء الوحيد الذي كان
يعرفه بالماضي
في هذه السياسه القمعيه للاسف شكرا
تتابعنا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
بعد فوزه باربعه 64 مقعدا كتله نتنياهو
اليمنيه تفكر بتشكيل الحكومه الجديده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلن ولي العهد السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان عن اطلاق شركه سير
لصناعه السيارات الكهربائيه اول علامه
تجاريه سعوديه لصناعه السيارات الكهربائيه
في المملكه وقال الامير محمد بن سلمان ان
اطلاق شركه سير يهدف لدعم تطوير المنظومه
الصناعيه الوطنيه وجذب الاستثمارات
المحليه والدوليه واستحداث العديد من فرص
العمل للكفاءات المحليه بما يساهم في
زياده الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للمملكه
خلال عقد المقبل ودفع عجله النمو
الاقتصادي تماشيا مع رؤيه 2030 ومن
المتوقع ان تجذب تاثير استثمارات اجنبيه
مباشره بقيمه 562 مليون ريال لدعم
الاقتصاد الوطني وانتصل مساهمتها في
الناتج المحاليل الاجمالي بشكل مباشر الى
30 مليار مع توفيرها لثلاثين الف وظيفه
بشكل مباشر وغير مباشره بحلول عام
2034 وتعد شركه سير مشروعا مشتركا بين
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
وشركه همم فوكس كين او
حيثما حيث ستحصل سير على تراخيص تقنيه
المكونات المتعلقه بالسيارات الكهربائيه
من شركه بي ام دبليو لاستخدامها في تطوير
المركبات
ينضم الينا من جده خالد شربتلي الرئيس
التنفيذي لتكنولوجيات الصحراء للاستثمار
استاذ خالد كيف يمكن للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم ان تلعب دورا اجتماعيا
اقتصاديا واقلاميا رائدا في مجال البناء
السيارات الوطنيه داخل المملكه
السلام عليكم
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
حفظه الله الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للصناعه
الاسبوع الماضي الهاتف الوصول الاقتصاد
صناعي اجانب للاستثمار يسهم في تحقيق
التنوع الاقتصادي وتنميه الناتج المحلي
لزياده الصادرات غير النفطيه والذي يهدف
لتحول المملكه لاحدى اهم الدول الصناعيه
المستوى العالم وصناعه سيارات هي من احدى
الصناعات الجوهريه واهم الصناعات الواعده
في المستقبل وبالاخص صناعه السيارات
الكهربائيه والتي طلب التكنولوجيا وتطلب
النظام الصناعات مختلفه
ان شاء الله تكون رائده عالميا في هذا
المجال وكما هي رائده
يعني اليوم ما اهميه ابتكار وتصنيع مركبات
بمميزات تكنولوجيه حديثه تتماشى مع كل
التغيرات العالميه والمناخيه في المملكه
تختلف طريقه انتاج السيارات التقليديه عن
السيارات الكهربائيه بشكل جدا كبيره بعض
المصانع السنوات الماضيه طريقه الانتاج
نفسها تختلف لاختلاف المكونات المكونات
سيارات التقليديه اكثر من 2500 او 3000
قطعه متحركه بينما السيارات الكهربائيه
حوالي 200 قطره ومن اهم الاختلافات هي
اعتماد السيارات الكهربائيه على
التكنولوجيا بشكل كبير بكل بساطه زي ما
احنا تحولنا من الاجهزه
التقليديه الاتصالات الى الاجهزه الذكيه
هو التحول ما بين السيارات التقليديه الى
السيارات الكهربائيه
والشراكه مع شركه
الصراحه من اهم النقاط لان شركه فوكس كونج
مصنع لعقل مايكروسوفت وعده همم شركات
عالميه وتمتلك تكنولوجيا بالاخص في الذكاء
الاصطناعي والبيانات الضخمه والتكنولوجيا
بشكل عام في تصنيع السياره
هناك اختلاف كبير وذلك نضع المملكه في
بدايه
صناعه جديده
ويعني يمكن المملكه ان تكون دوله رائده
فعلا فهذه السماعات وامثله الاي بي جالكسي
في المستقبل ان شاء الله
نتحدث عن صناعات متطوره صنعت في السعوديه
وهناك مفاهيم ومميزات مرتبطه بهذا الصناعه
هو المتوقع نفس التحول ما بين زي ما كنا
في الفاكس في التليفون وكل هذه الاجهزه
الى جهاز واحد السياره ستصبح شجر كبير من
حياه المواطن البطاريه في المستقبل يمكن
ان تشحن البيت في المساء على سبيل المثال
وممكن يعني
قياده الذاتيه ستغير طريقه الموبيلتي او
الحركه المستخدمه المدارس التي تغير من
اشكال المدن التي نعيش بها
يوم عده مدن اخرى جديده في المملكه
تطور او زياده في الانتاج السنوي لسيادتك
الكهربائيه بمعدل 30 بالمئه سنه اه ليصبح
حوالي انتاج على على عام 20 30 انتاج
سيارات كهربائيه حوالي 40% من اجمالي
انتاج السيارات في العالم يعني
ستصبح جزء من حياتنا اليوميه زي ما
الايفون سامسونج
شكرا لك استاذ خالد شربتلي رئيسه تنفيذي
للتكنولوجيات الصحراء للاستثمار حدثنا من
جده
اعلنت شركه نيوما السعوديه عن دخولها
باستثمار يقدر قيمته ب 175 مليون دولار في
شركات فولكوبتر لصناعه الطائرات العموديه
الكهربائيه ضمن مساعها للاستحواذ على حصه
كبيره من الشركه حيث ستعمل الشركه على
تقديم خدمات التكسي الجويه الكهربائيه في
نيوم لتسهيل الربط بين مناطقها المختلفه
مما في هذا العين واكساجن وتروجينا
وتستهدف نيوم انشاء اول منظومه تنقل
مستدام تنقل مستدامه عامه ومتكامله على
مستوى العالم وستتحول نيوم وفوليكوبتر
فكره التنقل الجوي عبر سيارات الاجره الى
حقيقه يوميا لسكانها وزوارها وستبدي كل من
يوم وفلوكبتر بالتعاون مع هيئه الطيران
المدني السعودي منصه اختبارات لدمج نظام
طائرات الاقلاع والهبوط العموديه
الكهربائيه مع منظومه قطاع التنقل
المستقبلي
[موسيقى]
تعد الانتخابات التمهيديه التي بدات مارسي
الماضي
وغيرها من بين اخر الجولات
التجديد النصفي التي ستحدد ميزان القوه في
مجلس النواب شيوخ المزيد في العرض التالي
لزميلا روان حمزه
معارك الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
انطلقت قبل اشهر بسباق تمهيدي لاختيار
مرشحي الحزب الجمهوري والديمقراطيه
للتنافس بالانتخابات النصفيه تصويت بدا
مبكرا في الاول من مارس في ولايه تكساس
ثلاث هولات في ثلاث من اهم الولايات
فلوريدا ونيورك وكلهما فلوريدا شهدت فوزه
كثير من الجمهوريين بفضل دعم الرئيس
السابق ترامب ابرزهم النائب الجمهوريه
احد اشد المناصريه ترامب والمؤيده
لمزاعيمه بشان سرقه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
فوز امتد الى ولايات حاسمه كم واريزونا
وبنسوفينيا مناصرون ترامب كانوا ايضا على
قائمه مرشحين لاختيار حكام عدد من
الولايات ومناسبه محليه منها ما يتصل
بالاشراف مباشره على الانتخابات العامه
ورغم بروزي دعم الرئيس السابق وحضوره بشكل
اللافعت الا ان مواقف اخرى شدت متابعه
للسباق الانتخابي التمهيديه فهناك قاعده
عريضه لمناهضي الرئيس السابق من داخل حزبه
خسارته نائب الجمهوريه الي سكيني في ولايه
ويومنج كانت مدويه خاصه انها عرفت
بقيادتها لتحقيقات ضده في الكونغرس
خسارتنائبه جمهوريه عرفت بانتقادها لترامب
علامه على قدره الرئيس السابق على اطاحه
معاديه وازاحتهم اما لو تحدثنا عن اهم
نتائج الدوره التمهيديه فكانت اختيار
الديمقراطيين في فلوريدا النائب تشارليست
الجمهوريه السابق في التنافس على منصبه
حاكم الولايه ضده واحد من ابرز الجمهوريين
راندي سانتوس
[موسيقى]
روايه
وانا بس انسى
[موسيقى]
مين الانتخابات الامريكيه الى الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه فمع انتهاء فرز الاصوات في
الانتخابات الاسرائيليه حققت كتله نتنياهو
اليمنيه 64 مقعدا تعد تلافا مريحا لحكومه
يمنيه قد تعمر اكثر من الحكومات الخمس
التي راساها نتنياهم من قبل في ما يتمتع
فيها حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرف ونجمه
اثمار في صقر النوعي اما حزب
اليسري فقد غاب كليا عن الخارطه
البرلمانيه بينما تراجع العرب الى عشره
نواب بعد ما اخفق حزب التجمع في اجتياز
نسبه الحسن زياد حلبي والتفاصيل
نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي المقبل
هذا هو العنوان والباقي مجرد تفاصيل فهو
الرابح الاكبر في الانتخابات التي اعطته
كتله يمنيه كبيره ومتماسكه قد تفضي الى
حكومه اكثر استقرارا وهي المره الاولى
التي سيراس فيها نتنياهو حكومه يمنيه
خالصه لكن نصبتها المتطرفه بسبب نجمها بن
كبير وحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه قد يضع
امامها تحديات داخليه وخارجيه
الجو المريح الذي استفادت منه اسرائيل في
الوضع والحلبه الدوليه اعتقد بان الحكومه
الحديه الجديده ستواجه صعوبات خاصه مع
الادارات الامريكيه ومع الاتحاد الاوروبي
على المدى القصير يمكن لنتنياهو بتوافق
مسبق ما احزاب اليمين ان يمرر قانون تغليب
قرارات الكنيست على قرارات المحكمه العليا
والحد من فعاليه جهاز القضاء
في ما قد يضطر لتوزيع الائتلاف لاحقا لان
فيه ثلاثه وثلاثون نائبا من الاحزاب
الدينيه والاستطانيه ينصاعون للحخمات الى
القوانين الاسرائيليه
وضبط الامور الامنيه الداخليه في اسرائيل
تحقيق الوحدات بين شرائح الاجتماعيه
المختلفه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وناسيه
ما بين المواطنين العرب واليهود خاصه على
ضوء الشراكهلافيه
للمتدينين واا جهات متطرفه الحكومي
اجرائيا تسلم اللجنه المركزيه للانتخابات
النتائج النهائيه الاربعاء المقبل لرئيس
الاسرائيلي وبعد ان يؤدي انه المنتخب
اليمين القانونيه منتصف الشهر في الكنيست
يكلف الرئيس الاسرائيلي
بتشكيله حكومه في غضون 28 يوما قابله
للتمديد قد يشكلها
»
اسرائيل الثانيه هزمت اسرائيل الاولى حيث
هيمنه الاحزاب الدينيه والاستيطانيه وتلك
المستنده اساسا الى اليهود الشرقيين وهزمت
النقب الغربيه واحزاب اليسار والوسط وبين
هذا وذاك فان الحكومه المتطرفه ستكون امام
اختبارات جديه داخليه وخارجيه ثوره
تشكيلها زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
قام بها مجموعه من العلماء على وجود ادله
تتعلق بوجود شاسع كان موجود على سطح كوكب
المريخ منذ حوالي ثلاثه فاصله خمسه
مليارات سنه وياتي هذا الدليل في شكل
تضاريس مميزه للشاطئ تم تحديدها من خلال
صور الاقمار الصناعيه العديده لسطح المريخ
هذا واكتشفت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا
في مطلع الاسبوع الماضي اكبر حفره عثر
عليها على سطح كوكب المريخ من خلال
البيانات التي جمعت من مركبه الهبوط
انسايت التي قامت الصدمات وقاست هذه
الصدمات الزلازل في وقت سابق
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
حزبوا عمران خان يتهموا رئيس الوزراء
ووزير الداخليه والاستخبارات بمحاوله
اغتياله
على اعدادك للقنبله قذره
زياره المستشار الالماني الى بكين تغضب
واشنطن والبشوز يتعهد بعدم تجاهل القضايا
الجذريه
الامير محمد بن سلمان يطلق من السعوديه
اول شركه لتصنيع السيارات الكهربائيه في
الشرق الاوسط